Speaker 1: The David Pakman Show
sub Reddit and now has nearly thirty
two thousand of our viewers and listeners
subscribed and participating. And
you can propose segments for the show. You can
engage with other people. Please don't troll
though. We do have moderators and we're trying to
keep the trolling down to a very, very dull roar.
A few posts that I do want to signal that I
found interesting. A bunch of different people
posting links to articles about the 30 year old
anti vaccine nurse who got covid and died. And
I'm glad to report on it. And a lot of
people have asked me to talk about it.
But the glee with which some people are saying
she got what she deserved, it's really tough
for me to get on board with that because I see
these people as victims. These are people who
fell for antiscience, right wing propaganda.
It's hard to cheer that. And the truth is,
I would rather her still be alive. And even if you
don't care about this one individual, think about
the greater good. We would still all be better.
How many people might she have spread the virus to
in eventually dying from it, even if it was based
on her decision not to get vaccinated because of
her beliefs? We're all better off if she gets
vaccinated and doesn't get sick and doesn't risk
passing it to others. So whether your motivations
are moral or societal or for other people or even
economic, because we know of the huge economic
cost for me, I'm just not where I know some of
the audience is in a sort of like total disregard
and lack of empathy for this woman. Also,
as far as we know, I mean, statistically,
she probably has some loved ones who did get
vaccinated and did do everything right. And now
they suffer as a result of her death as well. So,
listen, I get it at a certain point. There's it's
personal responsibility and you have to decide and
we can't force anyone to understand or accept the
science about vaccines. But I'm not where some
people in the audience are in terms of the total
disregard, lack of empathy and sometimes almost
glee about the fact that an anti VAX person died.
I mean, that's a tragedy. That is the tragedy,
right? That's what we're talking about. Ninety
nine percent of those who are now hospitalized
are not vaccinated. This has a very real impact.
But yes, an anti vaccine nurse who was only thirty
years old did get the virus and died. Another post
related to vaccination about how the CPAC crowd
over the weekend, we covered CPAC earlier in the
week, the CPAC crowd cheered as vaccination rates
were announced to not be that high. And this user
pointing out that the Republican Party is really
the pro death party and saying at this point, I
don't even have any long winded explanation beyond
the title. What more needs to be said? Vaccination
rates aren't meeting Joe Biden's projected goals.
Yay, that hurts Biden and it helps us, the
Republican Party. And it means a lot more people
are going to die needlessly. And so they cheer.
That was one of the most disgusting moments of
CPAC cheering the fact that there are millions
of people in the United States who by choice
are choosing not to protect themselves and by
extension, protect the people around them from
coronavirus. And as I said before, I am angry
at them to some degree because it's infuriating
what they're doing. They also are victims of the
fact that they've fallen for stuff that's not
true. They've fallen for it from the Republican
Party. They've fallen for it from the so-called
libertarians talking about medical freedom,
as if that's even remotely what this is about.
They've fallen for the conspiracies. They are
victims. It doesn't mean we can't be mad at them,
but they are victims. And I think it's
important not to forget that to some degree.
Lastly, someone pointed out
that what's up with David's pen?
And they wrote that sometimes my hands come
into the frame and I have nothing in my hands.
And sometimes I've got a Sharpie in my left hand
and then sometimes I have a Sharpie in my right
hand. And then sometimes it's a pen in the left
hand. And then all of a sudden the pennies in my
right. There is no rhyme or reason at different
points. During the show I may make a note on my
extensive legal pads that I have just off screen.
Sometimes I may use the Sharpie to cross something
out once I've made a statement about it on the
show, something I think about. There's really
no rhyme or reason to it. And I apologize if it's
distracting to. And even that noise may have been
distracting to people, I am not trying to do
anything other than stay on track and present
to you all the information that I intend to join
the discussion on issues ranging from importance
at the bottom end about my Sharpie use all the
way to the top end about people who are choosing
not to get vaccinated. You can find the sub,
read it at David Pakman Dotcom slash, read it.